malaysia is an expression of personal
sovereignty of creativity imagination
and maybe a little bit of dash of satire
we like to poke a little bit of fun it's
kind of easy to do that we have a tiny
country inside a gigantic country
i am president kevin baugh the president
of the republic of malaysia
this is my nation
welcome to the republic of malaysia
right over there is the united states
and right over here is our country
my nation
is a micronation which means a tiny
self-declared nation
usually located within another country
as is malasia inside the united states
the united states does not recognize
malacia although we did get a very nice
christmas card from president obama
i would say that the u.s considers a
sort of an extension of free speech
for the record we do pay taxes however
we call it foreign aid we've seen their
roads the us needs all the help they can
get so we're there for them
we like to do things that are different
and unique and unusual malacia
we are actually very proud of our
our space program
oh yes
malaysia does have a currency
it's called the valora
which means valuable in esperanto which
is our second language
we also have our measurement system our
total population right now is 32 and we
have our own time zone
many of our civil servants in malaysia
are mannequins because they don't
complain and they don't charge a whole
lot and never go on strike that kind of
thing
there are hundreds of micronations
around the world in just about every
country you can imagine
the conch republic which is key west
florida sea land very famous micro
nation located off the coast of britain
it's really an amazingly creative group
of people that decide they want to have
their own country
i originally founded the republic of
malaysia back in 1977 when i was 15 and
i just stayed with it through the years
it is a lot of work running malaysia
because i want malacia to be a
functioning nation i want it to be as
much like a larger nation as it possibly
can be
i love being the president of malaysia i
really do
second only to my family is one of my
great loves in life
you